hey adam how are you nice to see you are
you in canada right now
i'm in canada right now yeah we're
starting working
right now in toronto awesome
awesome nice place it's good to see you
nice to see you too
congratulations on this film it's a lot
of fun uh
there's a great messaging to it i
watched it with my kids and we started
talking about bullies
oh really yes that's nice
now your kids are against bullies i'm
guessing right
guest bullies yes did you get picked up
when you're a kid
i'm sure i got a few moments where uh
sure yeah like everybody else you catch
you catch a little crap you get scared
you're like what the heck is going
on why am i being picked on and it's a
tough
tough place for any kid it's it's it's
it's nice when it doesn't happen that's
what the the the movie's trying to
you know the movie's just a goofy movie
but ultimately it's trying to say
bullying is pretty stupid bullying it's
pretty stupid okay so because we're not
gonna have halloween this year most
likely we won't our kids won't even
right right a game called trick-or-treat
so you just have to pick trick
or treat okay i'm ready okay which one
uh trick or treat just that i i guess
treat
treat okay so your question for treat
what's the nicest thing someone has done
for you
uh
it's not very uh my wife did something
to me the other day that i didn't expect
ever to happen but but um
i can't get into that uh
i was shocked though i gotta say i was
like i thought i said i thought i knew
you
that's it that's like the best treat you
could get
it was a heck of a treat and it
literally was at 11 in the morning out
of nowhere
thank you you know what was a treat i
saw you what two years ago i think
that's where murder mystery were on a
bow with jennifer aniston oh yeah yeah
that was and we talked about the raptors
you know all of that um
have you seen it have you seen jen uh
what was that performance she did the
fast times at ridge mount high what did
you think of her as an actress in the
reading
i didn't see it i didn't see it i know
it was funny i i didn't i didn't get to
see it but i'm sure it was great and i
know that everybody loved her in it and
and she is one great girl anytime i talk
to her i'm happy
i spoke with her a few days ago maybe
maybe a week ago she's just cool just a
great girl
yeah she's a great girl and you know
when after you won the oscars i was
reading an article and you said that you
uh nominated for an oscar you said that
you want to make the worst movie ever so
what would that entail
i here's what happened i was on a howard
stern show
and we were talking about this and and
they and uh something came up where
i said if i don't get uh blah blah blah
i'm gonna make the worst movie a payback
whatever
yeah that's a joke but uh
what would the worst movie entail i have
no idea but i'm sure i i'd be
i'm sure i'm game to be in it i love you
man thanks for this movie it's so great
for the kids i really appreciate
it have a good have a good day thanks
guys